جرعه من الامل تلقاها الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان قبل جوله الاعاده في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه التركيه التي تعقد
يوم الاحد المقبل 5% حصل عليها صاحب
المركز الثالث في الجوله الاولى سنان
اوغان دعا مؤيديه ان يضعوها في الصناديق
دعم لاردوغان بهذا وعلى الورق قد تبدو
الامور محسومه لصالح الرئيس اردوغان الا
ان محللين يرون مع ذلك فرصه لمرشح تحالف
الامه المعارض كمال كليتش دار اوغلو اكثر
من مليونين وثمانمائه الف صوت حصل عليها
سنان اوغان يتوقع خبراء ان تتوزع في
الجوله الثانيه بين المرشحين كليتش دور
اوغلو سيبقي على اعتماده على الصوت الكردي
الذي اعطاه يعني اعطاه عده اصوات في
الجوله
السابقه اذا لكن ما يشكل عائقا بالنسبه له
وجود
كتله اعطته مثل ما ذكرنا الصوت الكردي
كتله تاتي الى في المعارضه مع اختلافات
جذريه بين اطرافها التي اجتمعت بطبيعه
الحال على اهداف انتخابيه مرحليه على
الجانب الاخر الرئيس التركي سيكون مدعوما
بحصول ائتلافه على اغلبيه برلمانيه وايضا
ثبات الفئات الداعمه له كذلك حاول اردوغان
اغلاق الباب امام
انتقادات المعارضه باعترافه بعد الجوله
الاولى بقصور حزب العداله والتنميه وحاجته
الى النقد والتقويم وما بين هذه التوقعات
والامال والتحليلات يبقى الاتراك
والمتابعين بانتظار لحظه الحسم عندما تكشف
صناديق الاقتراع عما تحتوي لمتابعه المزيد
من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات